hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos as they come out
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
are you garbage it's a show we sit down
with your favorite comedians we find
that they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day
down here aunt tooty's basement she's
got some laundry going so she might
cross the camera
just letting everybody know my co-host
is coming at you
from right next to me he lives for my
aunt toddy banter
he is the ceo of ru garbage he cooks the
books he keeps us
online he's got his name on the lease
goddammit cut the [ __ ] kids some
slack
the next time you're reaching for a best
pal gang do yourselves a favor
make it a kippy and give it up for kevin
james ryan hey what's up everybody
thanks for tuning in
as always as always please please make
sure you rate review subscribe on itunes
full video available on youtube
also patreon.com are you garbage help us
pay the [ __ ] bills you can get a lot
of bonus content bonus episodes
ayg you get episodes of hard feelings
which is me and foley behind the
curtains a little bit [ __ ] on each
other talking about our lives talking
about the show they ain't good
the whole nine yards uh and then also
for our top tier patrons at the end of
every month
uh we'll do a live stream where you ask
us questions we ask you questions the
best
and also when you join bringing us to
where we are at now when you join we'll
ask
your question when you join the patreon
we'll ask your garbage question on the
show
with a guest with a pal and how about a
nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the pride of the
chicago comedy scene
chicago we call him the magic man but
everybody knows him as t-bone
toby mcmullen everybody what's up i got
some [ __ ] italian beef with you nerds
we're gonna be taking shots right before
we hit the record button
the great state of chicago stadium city
god damn it t-bone t-bone just caught
like a nine-minute [ __ ] beating
tell you i need a hot roast beef
sandwich on a kaiser roll stat
i hate when people have pride for where
they're from oh it's the worst you can
make fun of long island all day i'll sit
on it with you
we know you don't trash back okay well
relax there all right thank you
i'm the bridal dog
it's like philly stinks i'm like yeah
dude i know like i'm not i'm not out
here repping it yeah let's transition
from the pride of the chicago comedy
scene to the embarrassment of greatness
[Laughter]
get a they put holes in the burgers out
there it's weird
gang this is a family episode we got a
special friend back here with us we got
a little company in the house
if you have not seen this episode make
sure you go back and watch it it's
absolutely amazing
he is our good pal he is a garbagio to
the 10th degree
from long island and he has a [ __ ]
brand new album out right now that we
could not be more happy or about and so
excited for him it's absolutely
fantastic
i hosted the show it was unbelievable
it's called not more than ever
nope no it's called not now more than
ever
[ __ ] idiot you're so close you dumb
dumb idiot i thanked you in the credits
you [ __ ]
and now i have to go back and edit and
get that out of there
somebody call up by dunes pull the plug
he has it we're in his defense
wait what he hasn't written down hours
he reaches you wrote it down
wrong yeah i said it i wrote it down
right not more than ever not not
now more than ever not now more than
okay well this is great organic plugging
we're doing here yeah said it nine times
yeah i'm leaving
not now more than ever is the album the
comedian
is brendan sagalow thanks the jacket is
shitty
yeah i mean look at you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i'm actually offended it
sucks
i can't wait to hear that album after
that the [ __ ] up it sounds like
it's so it's comedic stylings of nobody
how about that yeah well you're
i actually like the jacket that's why i
feel like i was like that's a nice
jacket
this would fit you great it sucks uh no
that would be a blanket on me
it sucks when you're like actually it
doesn't close by something someone says
and then you try to like get back at
them and it's just filled with your hurt
you're hurt you're not thinking comedy
you're hurt yeah yeah yeah
emotion takes over
brandon sagalow is with us here today
he's a good pal of the podcast
family episode as we said if you haven't
seen this episode
go back and check it out it's [ __ ]
absolutely amazing you have
one of the stories with people like when
we do other shows or whatever plug to
plug a yg people go
what was once you all right blew you
away you're a touchstone of what we use
on
other shows i'm just made out of garbage
because you used to live in what you
call
you used to sleep with as a kid as a kid
yeah
dude yeah man these wooden like things
your dad moved into your room uh-huh and
you slept in the living room which you
called the den
yes yes bad news on the couch right
there was no
couch on a white couch with a with a uh
what kind of blanket it was a
very shitty blanket with the holes and
it was like a quilt probably had a
sports team on it probably like a giant
no no no no my family doesn't didn't
watch sports
couldn't afford the gear also something
that sticks out a lot too
you were a big panda express kid growing
up right i
loved old p.e but it's so weird man
regular chinese is one thing
but to be like a panda expressway i
liked panda express because you got a
little free sample before you stood in
line
[Laughter]
they do the free samples that like
regular brick and mortar panda express
he's talking i'm just talking about the
mall wait that's where you would go and
get the food was it
yeah sometimes you go to the mall and
just get food at the food court
that's crazy no no no you go to the mall
just for this not all the time i wasn't
like oh i gotta go pick up food let's go
to the broadway mall
but i would uh i i you know if if we
wanted panda express we'd go to the mall
get some
panda express wow and then take it home
sometimes you would take it no no we'd
probably sit in the food court
i don't think the food court has to go
containers it's just on a tray
yeah wait the sagalos are stealing the
trays just eating it like pig
would you just take the wait hold on be
honest here
okay would you go to panda express to
get stuff to go home and take it home
and
not all the time but sometimes i would
yeah if we were in the air
did they would be rude if i didn't stop
by
if we were in uh if we were by the
broadway mall
in hicksville new york we would walk in
right now
you're looking for pinhead street over
there in gooberville
right down there of loser avenue i don't
know what accent we're doing
in chicago chicago that's what we're
doing shout out to hicksville
uh yeah so if we were in the area we go
let's go get some panda express
you walk in take the escalator up get
some panda it's still there i think the
panda express
that is a staple of that but i'm saying
like what kevin's saying is i don't ever
remember them having
you never to go to go boxes
at well like in the food court well they
no they they give it to you and to go
so it comes in those foam things and
then you just close the foam things and
go to your car and go home
oh okay or what we would normally do is
we go oh we're by the mall let's go get
some panda express and sit in the food
court get a table for two
light a candle johnny just gonna be the
two of us tonight okay
now they do like good fellas they bring
the table closer to the you got ideas
you guys coming through the janitor's
entrance some other tables complaining
hey we've been waiting an hour
all right buddy hang on right this way
one night the panda express guy sent us
orange chicken for free
that was so romantic so we know you're
trash
i'm a piece of garbage and a good pal
love you love you great hang
on fantastic gang fantastic album out
couldn't be more excited to have you
here
we're going to do a little uh what we
call a little family episode we're going
to ask some questions from the patreon
from the facebook group
from the fam out there all right i
couldn't be more excited
i love it thank you for bringing dunkin
donuts hey old for yourself
you are a duncan kid well i thought i
went what are the chances that they
actually have
anything for the guests pretty good we
always have water
there's a bag of cheetos over there if
you want to have any panda express sorry
around bringing it up to the broadway
mall you guys don't have any boneless
ribs that sounds like a one-floor mall
by the way
it's a it's a it is a one-floor mall it
is a one-floor mall but there are
there was a second floor one floor malls
are bad news i know it wasn't one
oh my gosh but there was a second floor
there was the second floor which was
just the food court and the movie
theater
okay so yeah do you think anyone oh i'm
sorry
mr rockefeller yeah i apologize six
dollar movie tickets
so snuck in did it matter would you
sneak in for another one
oh yeah we used to sneak in all the time
because what you could do
is if you knew where the doors led
because there was like the fire escape
people
dude if you got blueprints out to the
amc
i can see your dad on the hood of a car
with a map out over the
the security guard on the back is on the
tank
we're gonna sneak in for the right price
he'll look the other way all right you
grab the panda express and play
defense with the lady up front with the
tickets tell her you're a lost kid
you're 25. yeah yeah flirt with the slow
girl who rips the tickets
all right all right this is ah buddy i
love the family epps baby good times
easy peasy um guys so as you know when
you join the patreon we will read your
questions that's where these questions
have come from and some of them are home
[ __ ] runs uh it's always a good time
ah let's see here what do we got let's
do something good
this is from eric is it garbage to order
food for carryout
in order to not pay delivery fees and
tips yeah
yeah that's garbage and i do that i do
that every day you'll go you'll go pick
it up
yeah if i if i have the choice i'm going
to go pick it up because i do not want
to pay for tip i do not want to pay for
delivery fees
it's a huge difference if you're getting
burger king so like
no if you get burger king right my meal
is like
11 bucks but if i order it delivery
comes like 22. it gets up there
it comes it becomes 22. it's exactly
like doubles yeah
yeah what is your meal uh the oh the old
saggalow
the number 17 i make up i make them make
a number for me
three 15's and a two give me an 11. it's
a derrick gaines joke
i stole it oh that's funny um it's the
the bacon king which is a
double patty uh with bunch of bacon and
mayo
all over it with [ __ ] i'll get it
large too
i'll sometimes i'll get it medium though
because even the medium
you explained that like you were in
child therapy
show us where the king touched you there
is no shame like the shame of deleting
the mcdonald's app
off your phone after using the deals
yeah that's a pretty good one do you
have any fans what what food
apps do you have on your phone if any i
have no shout out to the perks on size
grubhub and seamless and stuff like that
the admirable it's legit i'm liking it
maybe duncan
maybe some dunkies dude i use it like
i've said before i use the starbucks app
and i feel like a millionaire when i go
in yeah that's classy
i feel like classy dude i feel that's
how well that's how garbage i am i feel
like i'm like you're not waiting in line
like that titan of industry like i walk
in and i'm like oh excuse me and i turn
like black people
duncan just it looks like shitty coffee
when you see it like remember that
picture that was uh
uh ben affleck like stumbling out of the
house with the munchkins and
they just look like two shitty coffees
but uh i felt so bad for him like leave
the [ __ ] guy alone i feel bad for
that guy catches a bad rap i love him
[ __ ] his love fantastic
i love him so much and he he really just
speaks to you if you don't look at that
guy
struggling in every picture and you know
yeah like oh that's me well cause they
catch him coming at his front door
yeah i was coming out the front door
with munchkins and a [ __ ] guy i've
been out on my front door for hours and
if you took a picture of me 20 minutes
ago it would be the same picture
munchkins all over you uh
covered in powdered sugar he dude him
smoking that zig
is like i'm that [ __ ] away from me he's
just like
dude his shoulders are dry he's just
defeated yeah yeah he's probably getting
his balls broke he's got a bunch of
million dollar deals cooking
and there's some [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
bushes across the street what the [ __ ]
man
now back to your original question i do
think
i understand when you say that if you're
doing it for like you know
to it doesn't matter why you're doing it
but sometimes going out and getting the
takeout
is all the emotional support you need to
feel good about the meal
does that make sense because you feel
don't you tell me you don't feel worse
about yourself
when you're getting burger king
delivered as opposed to when you got out
put shoes on
walked to the burger king ordered and
kept kidding i think that's
that's him going i was on the treadmill
for an hour
yeah i mean doesn't that make you feel
no
i can't that's a couple points on
nutrisystem if i'm getting burger king
delivery is
always makes me feel good it always
makes me feel better when i see someone
bringing it
yes but if i'm going to get some i get
what you're saying going against more
onion rings boy
[Laughter]
but like going to get a certain meal
like if it's not burger king or wendy's
or any of that fast food crap
yes i understand going out and getting
it that feels good so you feel worse
going into the place
yeah yeah seeing all those colors you
know what i mean like
it's so [ __ ] why would you want to go
into the crack house you know what i
mean get it delivered
yeah yeah yeah if they delivered crack i
would do it
what's your what's your fast food
rankings is burger king your number one
i mean my life has led to this question
my life is jack it off my life has led
freeze frames right there
and that's the question i've been
waiting for my whole life pulls out a
thing of chicken fries
like in no country for old men where
you're gonna ask me you're gonna tell me
to keep the quarter
has been waiting for you you've been
putting it up your whole life
i cannot choose for you you have to
choose he wasn't russian but go ahead
whatever it is um i'm gonna say this
right now
what's the spin-off that happened in the
ukraine wendy's first and foremost wow
okay it doesn't get any better than that
what's your name
it's a burger slash hot dog never seen
anything in my life
hold on uh what's your what's your my
order at wendy's is
big bacon classic no i i just get a
double cheeseburger
with large fries and large coke that's
it no frosty
frosty yes so i can dip my burger into
it you dip your burger into the frosty i
have from time to time that was a little
bit more of a joke but i have uh excuse
me
you've never done that big man yo you're
going to
be here fully fingers into the frosty
that you've never so happened that your
burgers never ended up in your frosty
frosty
listen i'm a dipper i'm a [ __ ] dipper
through and through
i know my fries have ended up in there a
lot so is your wiener
girlfriend to cover herself in frosty
could you cover yourself in a wendy's
frosty for me can we play wendy's
tonight
yeah yeah hey wendy i mean uh can we
play sweet and shower tonight please
call me dave listen i'm a big dipper i'm
a dipper to the point that people
they have said to me that's why you're
fat is because you always need something
extra
like you would say it's not the sauce
i'll tell you that when we were talking
about it's not the frosty you're dipping
[ __ ]
you're dipping your uh burgers into mayo
cups of mayo
okay something like that yeah
my instincts was to give up halfway
through i heard i was like don't give up
you're like you dip them in uh
you already did that you already did
that can't give up again
there's that long allen pride coming out
yeah i like it
no are you recording i'm a dipper
okay i've never dipped my burger in
frosty but i dip my fries in there i'm a
big fan of that
and i will dip my burger towards the end
when it's like you know like a crescent
moon and i can fit it into the ramekin
of whatever i was dipping the fries into
whether that's a chipotle mayo
or a honey mustard or a spicy mustard i
don't believe
you never dipped a burger in a frosty i
never
it just seems like it's such a basic
move too it doesn't mean that you're
trashier than me
okay but i just feel like it's something
that it's not like it's not a
competition is what i'm saying
i don't think it's a competition i'm
just going to say you're like well no
you he
i think you would prefer it if i did
well you have clearly let's put that on
the desktop
[Applause]
he gets so weird and defensive about
food stuff because he doesn't want to
appear like a fat guy the last thing he
has
are the words you don't want to feel
like a fat guy
a couple more black sweatshirts you'll
never see this guy yeah yeah um
it's like i'm not even there uh no he
does these things where like he'll see
somebody do something gross with food
and be like
you believe that guy you know what i
mean just to get the attention i've
noticed that actually
oh yeah i okay if i did do it
i wouldn't admit it here of course 100 i
would make fun of you for it to make
myself feel better
so what you're doing and then go home
and dip a burger in a milkshake yeah so
what bad idea
okay you want the truth yes yes hold on
a second there kids want to stop the
show for a quick
second and talk to you once again about
the stereo app
stereo is a free live broadcast social
platform
that enables people to have real
conversations
in real time the app also allows podcast
creators to build a more intimate
following
an intimate relationship with our
audience which we love here at ru
garbage
number one in customer service one year
running right here
are you garbage we love it okay it's an
absolutely fantastic app
because you can literally have a little
podcast studio right in your hands you
can do it from anywhere
it's going to be absolutely fantastic
and we're doing our first
live show january 28th at 9 00 p.m
january 28th at 9 00 p.m and in your
head you're probably thinking to
yourself wait a minute
i'm watching this new episode of are you
garbage the day that comes out
it is january 28th it is a thursday
holy [ __ ] 9 p.m i could see the black
and talk to the boys
let's go if you're watching this show
the day it comes out
we're going to be going live on stereo
app tonight it's going to be
absolutely fantastic okay ru garbage
could not be more excited to offer our
listeners
a new way to interact with us so we'll
see you guys tonight
and hang out the end of the episode
we're going to talk just a little bit
more about it
and get you guys all geared up and if
you want to jump jump ahead
you want to start getting on the ball go
to stereo.com ru garbage and sign up
today
i've never done it that's still not the
truth
i know you dude the listeners buy all
this [ __ ] i ain't buying it yeah i could
picture you just doing it
and then going and then i've gotten a
milkshake with a burger and fries and
bite and sipped the [ __ ] out of that but
i don't think i've ever had the same
type of burger
that actually seems worse in a way
because you're not like does it
well like when you dip a burger into a
milkshake or when you dip a burger into
a frosty it becomes one
piece of food but you eating it holding
it in your mouth and then going
to create this [ __ ] thing and who
tried of you
thanks for tuning in to are you diabetic
everybody
next week we have ralphie may and after
that john pinette
wilfred brimley walks in hold on there
fellas
um i'm gonna try it
yeah no don't you shouldn't be eating
wendy's we gotta we gotta get you to
lose weight
we don't need you trying i've been
chatting i don't need we don't need you
doing food stunts
yeah yeah foley's the type of guy who
takes the
smoke of the cigarette and drinks
chocolates and then it puts it in
yeah all right so double cheeseburger
was the original answer yes wendy's is
your number one i'm i'm basic with
everything so don't ask me my meals at
other any other place that isn't burger
king because burger king
all right snowden thank you hey wiki
eats
[ __ ] julian assange i'm very
political chicken nugget over here
don't ask me you [ __ ] the godfather
don't ask me about my business at arby's
uh okay yeah but just to cap this off
this is how it goes wendy's
mcdonald's burger king i [ __ ] hate
subway so that's not even on yeah
out of here and uh i mean what else do
you consist of taco bell
taco bell is the next one panda express
i assume would be up there
i haven't had panda express that's not
fast food that's good food fast
fast casual yeah no when i get chinese
it's like from a place that's
just number one china i assume we
probably go to the same
golden golden dragon yeah yeah that's a
window
yeah took place you guys ignore each
other when you see each other right
there
yeah it's just good day sir yeah
yeah we both walk in wearing trench
coats and baseball hats
it's like the departed yeah
mr johnson good day to you mr johnson
zach was like what are you doing here
he's like i owned a joint
i hope you cleaned up after yourself
great question they sit on park benches
facing away from each other and
slide back yes yeah yeah yeah zach
sits up and leaves a bag stands up
walking
meeting the washington monument um
all right this is uh this is for matt
this is one that happened in real life
with you we were okay i was [ __ ] uh
we were at a show on a roof
and i had a bot i had a bottle of beer
that needed a an opener so this is it
garbage to have a bottle opener on a
keychain
or refer to it as a church key it's r
it's trash to refer to it as a church
very true but i didn't know i remember
people like the church i've been out
at like a party people like church key
and i didn't know what they meant and
i'm like i don't know
i still don't even yeah yeah no i don't
believe in god
uh i don't think it's trash at all to
have a bottle opener on your keys sure
but also to set this
we were we were out of shape that's the
problem yeah
that's why you're here so look look is
it classier to have a bottle opener in a
drawer yes i guess so
but i look at that more as just a tool
it's a tool
that i use that i would use very often i
looked down on that for a completely
different reason where i'm like if you
can't open
a bottle of beer with a lighter like
what are you doing true
that but that's trash that's more trash
yeah to open up a with a lighter
well you know the ultimate trash way
it's hitting on the table no biting it
biting it biting it is table tables
tables tables
biting it is enough table a dresser to
motel six
yeah yeah yeah yeah i still have a chip
and a tooth from opening a bottle of
water
or just having the ones that [ __ ]
turn and open that's pretty trashy
what what do you mean just like a bottle
of twist open twist off
like a budweiser's twist off yeah you
think that's trashy to have a twist off
beer
yeah it's not the classy or the beer yes
yeah you're gonna water down dunkin
donuts something
and twist off is stretchy classy it's
less classy than a pot yeah it's
yeah yeah yeah it's first of all it's
usually what they went they went
some people don't have bottle openers we
want our
our customers to be able to just chug it
down their gullets sir what are people
who can't afford bottle openers
great job
get that man of promotion we're losing
half the market out here
i thought no i could be wrong if you
have anybody in the uh in the
in the beverage industry they can they
can clear this up i thought it usually
was now before the micro brew domestics
were twist off
imports were bottled were popped yes
because
everybody else does beer better than we
do americans are the worst
be before microbrews like budweiser
nobody cares about how it tastes
everywhere else has reverence for the
beer itself
yeah the way you're speaking it's like
the the cancer let's talk about that
tommy propaganda just came out of my
[ __ ] partner's mouth
uh no that's what it is i mean yeah
budweiser's shitty beer you're gonna
i don't i i love it let me look down the
barrel to america island
you believe this [ __ ] guy um i'm
gonna call ice on you dude
have a good time wherever the [ __ ]
you're from yeah yeah yeah good luck
ireland taking you back yeah yeah i
enjoy
germany well no they're all i mean i
don't
i'm actually pretty nice there that's
right beer is really nice too
yeah and it's all it's all [ __ ] pop
you know it's not a twist off
it's all [ __ ] you need a bottle i
know what you're saying i'm just yeah
whatever that's all i'm saying
if you need to if you need something to
open your thing it's classy yeah
thank you yeah it's more you're having
it no the easier they make to consume it
let's see your keys that's why that's
why waiting for a steak
is classy but if if steak was like fast
food where you could get it in five
minutes and shove it down on your way
on way to home then you're a piece of
[ __ ] it's pretty good that's bulletproof
logic right there
i like it but also when i needed a
bottle opener
this is like to set the stage i scan the
i scan the people who i could ask
and it was like you know like just like
the guy that working there this there's
like five people and i looked i got the
saga
it was like it was like a tracking
device like doo doo doo doo doo doo yeah
i'm like hello you got a bottle opener
yeah i'm surprised i didn't take off my
shoe and have it at the bottom of this
on the soul yeah i had a buddy with
those ones
can i see your keys right now can i see
your keys there's by the way
or did you leave them in the harley out
front
[Laughter]
get your motor running oh [ __ ] i i had
to hit the jukebox to make it work
uh hey uncle jesse relax i still got it
i'm 36 days sober
oh yeah congratulations congratulations
very much yeah and i still put it on
because this is an essential tool baby
you need one of these
i don't think so no i think you're
waiting to relapse
it's like inception this is my totem
yeah find out what's real or not the
reason i asked to see your key you have
a
you only have two keys i'm
[Laughter]
this is my wallet it's right it's below
my phone
this is where i keep all my [ __ ]
minimalist and then you go like this
right so you never really see fat
minimalists
and i don't think he knows nothing's
minimal i don't think i don't think he
knows what i don't like a lot in my
bedroom i take up a lot of space myself
i sleep standing up i was expecting
you to have a and i always say this
wrong a caribou
a carrot carabiner he says carabiner
once a week he's a scaraboo carabiner
i was expecting you to have your keys
they were for
for all of high school and college my
keys were on a carabiner that with that
hung from my
jeans and uh it's a big punk rock thing
it is a big punk rock thing and uh
because when you're in the pit
you can't have your keys falling off for
sure for sure but like
that's why you would have them there is
that why people put put them on those
things
no not because of the pit or anything
he's doing a [ __ ]
joke have you ever been in a mosh pit a
guy with a jacket like that's never been
in a pit
i create the mush pit baby yeah yeah of
course i used to go to floggy molly
concerts
and uh because they would play
hammerstein ballroom every year got
thrown out of hamilton march
and uh the play yeah dude i'll tell you
i'll tell you one time in like once i
was at miss saigon
no one time in uh college or or maybe
senior year of high school i was wearing
you went to college i went to three
colleges
okay did we know this i knew you did did
you finish
do you have a four year degree now you
don't have a four year three college
that's at least three years you should
be close three colleges
the more colleges you went the shittier
you are too do you have a four year
degree you have a bachelor's degree
i have a bachelor's degree yeah what
yeah yeah i have a uh
so i will i'll have you know did we ask
you this i actually
made the dean's list at nassau community
college wow
so no i went to sva i went to school
visual arts you had some chick that was
blowing the dean
[Laughter]
yeah just me and dee snyder asking hey
kids so who sealed the ocean blue
cyclone what'd you get for four
that's my d sniper and batman what did
you get for
four is so funny what'd you get for four
uh nassau was pretty shitty too
i went to school visual arts for one
semester where's that
that's in uh that's in manhattan dude
everybody i know has done that and new
york film school
and flunked out i didn't flunk out i
left
it was kind of a chicken and egg type
thing you can't fire me i
quit typing one of my biggest regrets
was leaving school of visual arts
because i was majoring in film and now
i'm like
you know i'm like creating these
sketches and [ __ ] so i wish i knew what
the [ __ ] i was talking about
then i went to so i left sva and then i
went to nassau community college and
this is get back on my feet a little bit
yeah yeah yeah school of visual arts you
came in here
okay you left home you're staying here
did you live here did you commute from
long island
i lived in manhattan nice on 23rd street
right now
right down the block are you the first
sagalow to ever live in manhattan uh
no they came to thanksgiving at years
yeah my dorm and uh
nassau i went to which i'd have to walk
through like rap rap
battles and stuff it was really cool um
wait so
how many years were you at school of
visual arts i'm sorry one semester
one semester and then you decided did
you immediately enroll right into that
in the spring semester
i immediately i i told my parents i
wanted to leave school visual arts
and then i went to nassau community
college which where i made the dean's
list
and then and i was there for about a
year and a half you were there for a
year and a half
you moved back in with your parents yeah
back to the den yeah did you have your
own room at that point
yes i did have my own room because my
dad was out of the house
okay and then uh you know
king of the castle and uh
and then i went to pace university and i
finished college there
wow yeah so you came back in the city
pace is in the city pace is in the city
it's in lower manhattan you commute
every day
no i i dormed in friday
uh communications if you can't tell wait
hold on
so i assume communication school of
visual arts none of the credits
transferred over
none of them no so you did a year and a
half so you did three semesters
at nassau county community college yeah
and then
the other two and a half semesters yeah
i forgot
where it paid so you were at peace for a
pretty good time for for a long time
yeah
okay and you were the normal age of like
the regular i think i was a year older
than everybody
i i don't remember i don't know is that
he's out front on the hood of a camaro
i love these college girls you guys got
any
folders where's my traffic
i'm a five-star kind of guy you girls
know what a dean's office is
it says i gotta talk to this bozo i get
into a fight with another group and i
take out a pr
um no the pointy [ __ ] the
the protractor yeah he did this he did
[ __ ] metal horns
yeah let me know what it is bruh i've
had a long day
[Laughter]
have you well when you wake up at two
[Laughter]
shout out to all the people that started
hitting me up and say they've been using
daddio in every day
daddy i still i got to be honest that's
that's not a kippy original i saw that
for my cousin liam
well well he stole it from the 50s i
know but i'm just saying
it's not like i just started saying it
one day hey cool cat sorry that's not me
that's my uncle
what's up dawg i didn't think about that
oh man this is too fun
um all right let's see this is from
dum-dum i'm very guilty of this have you
ever used febreze on any other
uh fab or any other air fabric freshener
on your clothing
are you kidding me you mean cologne
you mean president what are you wearing
springtime mist
yes hawaiian breeze who makes that i
uh i never wore i mean in the
in when it's absolutely needed which is
like if you stay at somebody's house or
something and then you get up and you
smell like [ __ ] or whatever then you put
it on
um it's good on the road i will say this
we this is pretty trashy me and my
friends in high school
we would take febreze and we thought
because it was like you know it's like
it's like lysol or whatever it would
poison you so we would spray the wall
and just smell it for like 10 minutes
and try to get high off of that
man wow shout out to patients shout out
to facebook now we know how you made the
dean's list
[ __ ] those doors
have you ever huffed axe body spray
huffed it
uh no no never that's disgusting you get
dust off like a [ __ ] gentleman
yeah yeah yeah dust off that was huge
that was awesome dust off or
terrible for you that yeah yeah yeah
real bad
yeah yeah i have a friend who killed
himself that way wow by doing just
shout out to pace university daddy
that's my roommate that's all i got on
the dean's list
i was actually the dean of the school
yeah uh did we did he did he do that on
purpose to commit suicide or just odd
uh nobody knows it's it was it looked
like an accident but his
could have been murdered
tune in tonight on hlm
nobody knows long island dirtbag
there were two footprints in the snow i
believe it was colonel's sleazeball
when the cops arrived the door was
locked from the outside
[Laughter]
no but he was one of those guys where
like we're like oh
he knew how much you know he knew what
he was doing
um wow but like whip it is awesome dude
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] cool yeah man
drugs are cool drugs are great i mean
you could tell
by this jacket um
i remember growing up i remember when uh
what was downy wrinkle release do you
remember that [ __ ]
getting high off that no i'm just saying
in general jesus christ man
let me get a tide pod out the lungs a
little bit hey do you guys get down
[Laughter]
more of an all temperature cheer guy
i have 100 used for breeze in place of
changing my clothes that's mine can i
have a water oh i know have you ever
been on a show before you [ __ ]
i'll try to do it without uh jesus but
me
well we're sitting here he just grabs my
water i'm like that's mine i go out
i was going like this oh well i'm soby's
also not the intern
i don't what am i supposed to do get up
on the [ __ ] t-bone i'll do one
there's there's some in that bag
actually
you could have rode it out for another
45 minutes i'm very thirsty
thank you thank you i'll get your ice
there too you could have crushed
yeah that's better for that foley's just
pissed because he bought the waters
today
oh wow we'll be drinking all the waters
you guys share one all right
i'm cutting out anything funny brennan
says from heroes
trim them down he's only gonna have to
cut three things
gonna be an easy night for t-bones god
damn that was i really almost choked on
the water trying to get that out
that's what they'll never get how hard
we're swinging we're trying our best
listen i have 100 percent used for
breeze in
replace of changing my clothes i have
specifically sprayed the butt
on the jeans where you know where it
could be a problem where the [ __ ] was
yeah
[Laughter]
oh that's bad oh like no i've definitely
done that on my
shirts the whole nine yards get axe man
get something else you don't need
get something specific i don't like that
the good thing about febreze
is it's not that strong smelling it kind
of it dissipates quickly
you're not covering up you're
eliminating shout out to febreze
uh it eliminates it rather than [ __ ]
really like clones it up you know
yeah but you don't remember bounty
wrinkle release or that whatever it was
downey wrinkle really hey
relax junkie jones i never use this
stuff sorry
doing that you get your fix right
here's cousin invented daddio and eating
tide pods no i just remember when that
[ __ ] dropped my mind
i thought it was like the space
technology yeah what is it
instead of you spray it on and then you
like wipe the wrinkles out
just me okay also i got this is a
personal were you a steamer family or an
iron family
nobody was a steamer family i got like
90. i got a i had a couple of buddies
that were steamer family what yeah
what yeah what's crazy to me what did a
steamer in the 90s look like
what do you think it was just called a
dry cleaner i think it was a salesman i
think she was korean
no but my family was a big iron big
ironing
white death of a salesman because that
you know when you travel you need to
take a steamer with you
oh do you take a steamer with you when
you travel no but i should
just take an extra pair of sweatpants do
any of you own an iron or do i assume
you all do
shower steams to get wrinkles no i got
an iron i got a nice steamer i got a
[ __ ] dry cleaner i got a laundry mat
old nine yards yeah i got an iron yeah
do you iron your own
you still do the [ __ ] hanging in
there hanging in the shower
at what point have i needed a shirt to
be unwrinkled in the last 10 months well
starting next week i want a [ __ ]
slacks and a tie on you every day
yeah i always thought it was pretty
trashy that we had
um you know the uh uh
wait what we just said slacks and chino
that goofy guy you're an old comic right
and then you tuck one into the other he
doesn't know what he's doing most of the
time
he doesn't know what we're saying or
what he's saying yo you calling me an
alt comic is the meanest thing you've
ever said to me
listen always blacked out for most of
the show you know the hey segalo what
the [ __ ]
you got a new album coming out it's
called now norm more than never
called i love now in laters
i hear it's mostly country songs
[Laughter]
you know you know the clothing rack it
was wooden and you would like
you you would make it yourself it what's
it called it would compress
and then you would hook it no nobody
knows what i'm talking about
i hate this what are you asian what are
you talking about what are we talking
about
my mom had one and we she would just dry
the clothes in the house on it
not put them outside we we had a
clothesline for a little while and then
we had a clothesline having a
clothesline is [ __ ] trash dude
having a cloak not but not in the summer
when you put the sheets out there and
then you can run through it like aladdin
man i did that for sure dude i for sure
did that
wow that one just hit me in the heart
right one step ahead
gotta go to pandar express now
that's no joke we're dining in tonight
[Music]
[Laughter]
he didn't run through the [ __ ]
laundry you know you missed out were you
were you we had a dryer yeah so did we
still do yeah you slept in the foyer
take it easy john john
yeah i know i did say that we had a
dryer
i doubled as my bed
[Laughter]
that was too much yes i apologize it's
okay uh
man i am having a good time here this is
from tyler onto patreon over here
uh do you put ketchup on your eggs which
i don't know
i'll smash that [ __ ] computer right
now who the [ __ ]
i don't think that's trashy though i
think i don't do it either but i think
it is the more i think about it the more
i think it this question made me think
it's trashy
because you're just eating the ketchup
wait a minute yeah
yeah scrambies are a delivery system for
ketchup
are we talking scrambling that's what
we're talking about that's trashy a good
egg you don't really need if you're
doing the yolk and everything
it's over sorry farm fresh freddy listen
bozo adults eat ketchup
any time anybody takes a hard stance on
food fully just immediately disagrees
adults don't eat ketchup yeah well i
mean this is also coming from a guy who
shower who's talking about insurrection
over here
horrible the only thing that i think
ketchup should go on is hash browns
hash browns or a hot dog from jerry's in
chicago's
you know about the great city of chicago
is you never put ketchup on a hot dog
you [ __ ] lose
it's golden's mustard listen
hold on slow down as we know we've
discussed this first of all thank you
for the question
he also answers it like he's only like
he's on a [ __ ] debate this is so
ridiculous
yes you put it's not trashy to put
ketchup on to put eggs
to put ketchup you can't even get me all
[ __ ] hot it's not trying to put them
on elevators
ketchup on eggs is is what it's there
for that's a
this is a very polarized i don't i i was
i i
a little bit so first of all scrambled
eggs a little melted cheese in them and
some [ __ ] catchy on there
but make a little make a little eggy
sandwich on the with the toast i don't
know why you do baby talk anytime you
talk about breakfast eggy
little cheese cheetos put it in my tummy
tummy with the aeroplane
oh my god little double stuffed baked
potato look at your little
yeah uh i don't know i'm leaning toward
i could be suede
it's not classy hot sauce and ketchup a
little sweet and spicy come on
no you gotta picture yourself okay if
you're like uh
you know if you're like at a really nice
place like a like a a
a country club right and you order eggs
will the eggs have ketchup on them
on them that would it's not gonna come
out but it's also like your name
is doing it for you well the fancy
yourself put yourself at that table at
the country club can i get a side of cat
they
they would bring out ketchup they either
going to have it in a night i think they
give it to the country
i think they give it to them because you
get potatoes it's for the potatoes it's
not for the egg no they're giving you a
nice aioli at a nice place like that
it depends how nice of course it is
we're talking private semi-private
public what are we talking about and now
what are you basing this on so i've
never seen on television
you've only gone sledding at a country
club
it's the groundskeeper everybody's
splitting
meet up with the panda express they said
they closed it five i don't know
peter but the panda express is so funny
uh no i know nothing about it i'm just
saying if i picture myself
at a country club am i seeing ketchup at
on any of the tables
no i disagree it depends i don't know
the classier restaurant you go to the
less catch-up you get
right it's one we can say it's not
classy it's not classy i'm not saying
this
you have to agree that it's putting
ketchup on eggs is not classy i ate at
answer the question you're honest what's
what's the question you're on i've asked
you four times
who's asking the question of the judge
objection
answer the question have you ever been
in court
no i'm not a [ __ ] criminal [ __ ]
rich guy over here gets to grill the
[ __ ] judge
do you know who my dad is
tell him to call me please um what's the
question
is you can you can admit that putting
ketchup on eggs is not classy
if if you disagree with that we're
canceling the whole show here on out
i'll admit that it's not classic okay
all right
per se if i'm at a chick-fil-a or
something
um sometimes it's the only classy answer
it is delicious
and it's it's i'm not going to say
whether it's classy or garbage
but is it it's no why would you want to
do what the show it's a thing why would
you want to play a game
it's a thing yes so yeah it could be a
trashy
i'm saying i think it's a trashy thing i
think i have it locked down on why it is
unequivocally trashy because no matter
where you get ketchup
it will always be heinz or hunts matter
how nice the place is
nowhere nowhere is making their own it's
always nice it's always covered
in ketchup okay but it's not i it's the
exception of the rules that's kind of
trashy too
that's like that's like point zero i
just worked at a place that made its own
ketchup yeah
look no matter what couldn't afford to
eat there but my [ __ ] batter away his
own moonshine it does make moon sign
classy yeah
no matter what ketchup is a piece of
[ __ ] because whatever you're getting it
from the bottle is farting at you when
you're done with it
so with a little bit of pre-cum yeah
yeah yeah yeah
nothing that nothing that when you're
done pouring it goes
yeah it's classic yeah that's true there
you go no dirty martini comes out like
that
and also if you can you can just a
hollandaise sauce container doesn't do
that if you can exchange the condiment
with another tape like hey you're done
with that and then put it on your table
it's trash how do you feel about that
are you that can you do that
hey you done with that ketchup that's
the most trash but yeah you could do
that
what about singing happy birthday to
somebody when it's not your table when
they come out and they're singing
you join in yeah i'm always in i like
performing so he breaks out an electric
guitar
i stand on the table i go happy birthday
one more time with feeling and a one and
a two
i'm yelling at the waiters at fridays
what about um saying it's your birthday
to get a free dessert have you ever done
that
i've done that at a bar to get free
booze i've walked into a bar and i've
been like it's my birthday and everybody
buys me shots and [ __ ] and then i walk
out
[ __ ] a free man you wait you walk
into a bar wouldn't your friends have
been there too
well i'm with my friends i'm gonna tell
everybody it's my birthday
oh that's pretty good that was big for
me when my uh buddy pat would get way
too drunk
at a bar and ultimately a fight would
happen you know like some guy like he
would just
grab someone's ass he would do what he
would call crab and he would go around
just grab people
yeah yeah yeah uh so we would get in
fights all the time to explain his poor
behavior yeah hey sorry man so
it's his birthday we're playing a game
called sexual assault he only did it to
guys
uh so he would get so people like you
[ __ ] this guy just grabbed my [ __ ]
ass like every [ __ ] time
yeah he's really [ __ ] up it's his
birthday yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all
right all right i'll let him go
we're taking him home right now one time
i got so [ __ ] hammered this is
another rock bottom moment for me
and uh we're all at paddy mcguire's
shout out to patties
patties this is back when the world was
open and i'm hanging out we're all there
the comics the wait staff from new york
comedy club and i turned to uh
christina who's you know the head
waitress in new york and i go
watch this i'm gonna make you laugh so
hard there was a girl at the bar talking
to her boyfriend she has her phone
out of her pocket in her back pocket and
she's uh
she's just i didn't know these people
and i go i'm going to try and steal that
phone oh
i'm going to give it back but i'm going
to see if it's so bad when you get one
of those ideas yeah
i'm doing it and i'm going i'm going i'm
going to pickpocket i'm gonna show how
good i am at pickpocketing
and christina the whole time is going
don't do this don't do it like it
sobered her up
yeah to be like don't [ __ ] do this
and i walk over and she's like taping me
so christina goes there's no way i'm
gonna stop him because i will
i will take i walk right up to her i
grab the phone for the second
she immediately notices just starts
screaming at me what the [ __ ] you doing
i start laughing i'm so sorry i was just
sorry
walk away and then christina has to fix
the whole thing yeah he's [ __ ]
hammered
his birthday what about the boyfriend uh
yeah he wanted to kick my ass too yeah
yeah but nothing happened [ __ ] i know
what a [ __ ]
what a killer pickpocket is chick
that's what you thought watched him pull
her away yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know in your head of you was
like if i'm if i'm
not doing well the only reason i'm
saying it now is to get ahead of it just
in case
just in case it comes if there's any
success in my career if this album
really pops and
uh you end up on the yeah that's too far
um all right this is from jessie ray
riot uh ever cruise around in your car
uh with ever cruise around your car in
the middle of winter with all the
windows down with the stereo cranked up
to look cool
[ __ ] yeah i'm a big fan of did it last
week son
oh yeah i'm huge with uh blasting the
music outside
and also a big fan of in the summer
windows down ac
on winter time windows down heat on
blasting
feels great i guess [ __ ] mother earth i
guess
yeah right really letting it all hang
out cover my whole body in toilet paper
go kick a couple of seals yeah yeah
take a torch to the polar ice caps
whatever
um yeah that was big especially when you
got it when you first got a car
yeah i went and put [ __ ] speakers in
it yeah a head unit
and [ __ ] 50 cent was hot oh yeah the
first song i listened to was bumping
many men and driving
yeah dude [ __ ] blasting juicy by by
notorious b.i.g here's the difference
though your garbage if you do that
you're [ __ ] trash if you get to like
a stop light or something like that and
you don't turn it down
when you're moving that's okay if you're
the [ __ ] who sits there for long
periods of time
you're [ __ ] sure i did that a lot i
did that a lot i was always like these
people want to hear this
i really thought that yeah sags
oh cool okay corey you're in high school
you have some buddies or a chick in your
car and you want to prove how cool you
are with the music
selection what are you putting on uh
like rap rap music rock music stuff like
that the stuff that i like
no not genre i'm like like band specific
i feel like everyone has something they
put on the show
probably like green day or something or
like eminem or whatever do
i don't know this answer but how many
green day tattoos do you have i have one
green day okay
we've discussed this brandon is the
level of trash where he has
the tattoo of an actor who played a
famous writer in a movie rather than
the actual writer yeah i have johnny
depp on my channel johnny depp
as um right by my heart hunter s
thompson
yeah yeah and i just got this new tattoo
yesterday this is piece of [ __ ] i got a
uh
neon jacket's coming off i got a neon
flamingo
cause i always thought that would be
pretty cool to get that's pretty cool
actually i'll give you that all right
yeah i mean for you that's the thing
it's also a tattoo so no friend could
ever be like
dude dude i remember you know it was big
when my friends you can't [ __ ] on it you
know you can't be like oh my all my
friends got that when they first
we're all words they all got words or
something
words are so like my buddy got loyalty
down his leg and he was like the most
unloyal guy like dude he was like
banging people's
wives and [ __ ] and like he literally got
the word loyalty on his and we were like
what yeah yeah dude
he we literally called it the one time
we caught him stealing from our other
buddy he was stealing a jimi hendrix cd
he got caught putting in his cargo his
cargo pants it's just like
dude i have a friend and then people
would get just like only god can judge
me
or like what's that the aaa thing i have
a friend who has the please accept me
for the
things the things i cannot exchange blah
blah blah all down his [ __ ] chest
i put a drink over here uh
yeah there's so many so many uh i
just remember being like another like
dude look at this like yeah the fonts
cool i guess like i don't know what do
you want me to say words are so trashy
and that's coming from a guy who has the
word punks on my hand wow what's the
origin of that this is the green day
tattoo
warp tour 94.
did you get that universe 2003.
uh billy joe armstrong has this tattoo
right there
yeah wow i got it wow
you ever do that no you were younger
than them correct
yeah they're like older than you yeah
they're they're like in there they're a
little bit older than me
they're in their like late 40s yeah so
they're a little bit older than me i
just want to make sure
so that was the that's not listen you
because you that's what i'm saying
you take a lot of 29. yeah you're 29
years old
yeah so you take a lot of [ __ ] for
liking green day
and like what do i don't know what he's
getting at i'm gonna say
it makes sense because you're younger
yes than them so you it was okay for you
to look up to them
it's not like you were a 40 year old man
okay it would be weird for you to look
up to
if i had a [ __ ] green day you don't
look up to people that are like
younger than you or anything like that
look up to me i admire them
but i wouldn't go so far as to get them
tattooed or like
well of course yeah i know that well
it's different once you have tattoos
getting another
the the barrier to entry is way easier
like i'll do this
i was also [ __ ] i was uh like 22 when
i got this yeah i mean yeah i would i
wouldn't like go get a billy eilish
tattoo
like make that a part of my identity no
but i'd probably get something that was
like
i wouldn't get like mac miller's name
written on me but maybe something
a la but he's also about your age right
he's young he was younger
way younger yeah that way but younger
yeah he was about two years younger than
me
huh all right two years i'll give you
yeah i
because i admire the guy i love his
music so okay you know
but i probably wouldn't get a tattoo but
it would be like i don't know maybe
something you get a mac miller tattoo
we ain't talking about it jack miller's
a great guy he's a great artist
no i'm not [ __ ] long island trees
[ __ ] come from a nice family
philadelphia i didn't sleep in the
living room
you also have a 57 chevy tattooed oh
that is you
i thought that was travis barker or does
he have the same one i don't know what
he has but i have a ford
which when i go to attack have you ever
been in a ford thunderbird not oh my god
this is got a tattoo of a car he's never
been in this is from like i feel like
all of your tattoos were on the wall
yeah dude tattoos yeah dude this is
yo sweet skylark bro
[Laughter]
yeah i got a four taurus on my chest
the wagon edition yeah yeah yeah no this
is
what's really trashy about this and the
flamingo tattoo
was i just googled neon flamingo and i
took like something from the first page
and gave it to the guy what's up brooke
you put this on
the same thing with this i just googled
like i don't even remember the date of
this but it's like ford thunderbird
57 or something like that and i just i
have a man's car a car on my
just some guy's car yeah just some guy's
car that he was oh really it's an actual
picture of a car
yeah holy [ __ ] jesus dude
that's jerry olaski's car i know
he lives down in boca now he was a
periodontist that guy was a pedophile
you're just doing the jon voip it from
seinfeld
oh yeah you just did that [ __ ] word
for work no i didn't
jon voight was a periodontist that was
it and then i mixed a little bit yeah
but you got jerry
you got john voight's call you got john
voice lebaron you did the band
okay i'm not called not talking [ __ ] i
just think it's funny
you didn't have a coke
[Laughter]
yeah um all right all right all right
let's get uh this is from jason vincent
he's asked us a couple of times and i
never got to it he goes
i just want to know if anybody had a
rubik's cube as a kid that never got
solved
that's [ __ ] hilarious that i feel
like that could be on a t-shirt
i knew that was never gonna i didn't
think you
could i remember i remember junior high
somebody somebody did and i was like i
never even yeah i mean i went home and
told my parents yeah junior highlight i
think i've known the smartest person on
earth
yeah no i never bought a rubik's cube
because i knew it would never get done
yeah i knew it would just be a fun
we got i was more of a magic eight ball
kind of game yeah yeah yeah that did the
work for you yeah
well i ever solved the rubik's cube the
future looks bleak
that was there was solving the rubik's
cube when i was a kid the big thing was
somebody
beat mike tyson's punch out on nintendo
nice
and they video taped it somehow no one
ever saw the tape but
it's always somebody's cousin's friend
yeah yeah yeah somebody's cousin
here's a here's a here's a question when
you uh when you
did something at an arcade where they
asked for your initials what did you put
you put s well some of them would block
out your dude i can't put ass
yeah i always put ass yeah i never got
that highest score to be honest with you
he was more of a snack bar kind of guy
he had a high score there
they gave out tickets for eating pizza
yeah
i'm on amazon right now i'm ordering a
rubik's cube for the studio we'll put it
in the background
if any guest solves the rubik's cube i
will give them two hundred dollars no
guest is gonna be able to sell don't do
that because
anyone could solve a rubik's cube you're
just throwing away 200 bucks yeah yeah
you're throwing away 200
of our money yeah yeah you're not saying
you're you you you're throwing this
ain't coming out of the slush fund i'll
tell you that i'll tell you what a
rubik's cube
cash we'll give you 200 and you'll give
them 200. yeah yeah yeah
it's a rubik's cube is not as hard as
you think there it is there's no it's
not
there's a pattern there's an easy system
there's an easy system it's like
it can be any one can be you can mix it
up however you want it can be solved in
like nine terms yeah i mean you should
be giving 200 bucks to someone who could
explain string theory but that's how
confident i am
in the lack of ability of rubik's cube
solving and anyone who will ever be on
can you do it at all
[ __ ] no no oh you're saying if a guest
can do it yes
oh i thought you went like a listener
[ __ ] no something oh next week
next week i just booked uh rubik's cube
champion of 2020.
[Music]
soda comes in it's like the queen's
gambit oh hey okay
rubik's cube oh yeah oh yeah
that was very chicago toby by the way
i'll give two hundred dollars
cash money right now 200 bucks i got it
and me
200 bucks might be the trashiest that's
good you think it's a lot of money
yeah somebody somebody listen i'm guilty
of this too somebody who says that
they'll give you money for doing
something
you usually don't got the money yeah
i'll give you 500
right now you [ __ ] eat that whole
thing one of the biggest things this is
how trashy i am and how trashy of a
family i come from
uh my cousin married a dude who played
in the nfl and made a lot of money hey
dude i know exactly you're talking about
red farms and lives in [ __ ] my
hometown all right
hey hey keep the big man's name out of
this you know what i mean um but he had
a lot of money
right yeah and he's a partier he was
like an offensive line so it was just he
was just a big partier yeah
love the booze and i was a poor comedian
for a long time
and still am oh yeah yeah i was like he
would buy you and sell you
oh part of him would he get and he would
be like ah
yo 100 bucks you could do that like jump
in the bay and swim to that and i was
i used it like an atm machine every time
i went down the shore dude yeah it's
people like 300 bucks to do this i'm
like
my clothes are awful yeah i'm late on
rent do you want me to eat any bugs for
you
kevin goes down the shore and turns into
stevo just doing fear factor for 100
i'll eat this dirt right now i swear to
god dude eat those nightcrawlers how
much
ah good stuff good stuff this is from
dave smith have you ever pre
not the comedian have you ever pre-med
uh have you ever prematurely cut a cast
off or helped a friend cut a cast off
oh uh no no no no did you have i
pictured you had a castle i did have a
cat
on your arm yeah yeah on my arm yeah i
remember i mean
it was one of four places it was either
yeah you guys are just running out of
trashy things you're like did you have a
cast
on your arm i knew it this guy's trying
and it was bright orange
and it definitely had lyrics what was
that my i was i was told that they were
for
uh trashy people no i was always because
i used to
i inquired about it my mother said that
would never happen i would never let you
get one of those
what i think they were more expensive
than a regular plaster dude
first of all you never you never got a
plaster cast yeah i did
no proper stop it's not more expensive
than plaster because the plaster isn't
the color it's the
the the wrap that they put around you
you didn't get a plastic
how [ __ ] the good doctor yeah yeah i
went to med school
it's really trashy you ever do this you
ever do this thing anywhere you [ __ ]
you go like that has it has a guest ever
done anything that's like
popped the microphone no we haven't you
go
and then check that out i like how we're
surrounded by like ten thousand dollars
in equipment he's lighting all five
there's smoke coming out of there uh
that's
a question for next time
not so smart now are you school of
visual design
what the [ __ ] are we talking about oh
they called the cast yeah yeah
no it's a wrap and the you could get any
color you could get anything free or is
it costing
it's free because i wanted to get the
colored uh rubber bands on my braces
that's why i brought it up
don't say colored the different colors
ones yeah i got you
um and my mom said no because that's
true
expensive now now did you do the math as
a 45 year old do you think the blue
rubber bands were more money
if demand was high in kids thought it
was cool no it wasn't supply and demand
i mean what's a rubber band cost you me
i don't know
personally i don't deal
with you i'm more of a staple guy and
you want to run my business and you one
of
us um i had a glow-in-the-dark cast
and i thought i was one time how many
times did you break something
i had this broken for like two years and
so they just had to keep rap
yeah yeah it was bad but the one time
they were like i went through like every
color he's like we got glow in the dark
i'm like laying on me dude let's go
i'll be a real big piece of trash that's
awesome i thought i was so cool
you could go to cosmic [ __ ] thing in
the world glow in the dark is great
though anything glow in the dark when i
was a kid i used to [ __ ] let go yeah
because you didn't believe it you were
like how does this is a color that
it glows yeah anything from a cereal box
that was glow-in-the-dark
one that couldn't have been good for you
no two [ __ ] fantastic
oh yeah when you figured out if you put
a light if you put it really up to a
light yeah yeah yeah
fully charged yeah right yeah that was
awesome
um all right this is from nate did you
ever [ __ ] with your neighbor's tv from
outside with the universal remote
what are you dennis diminished no the
[ __ ] is that oh wait i might have
actually did that
yeah i did yeah i might have actually
done something like that but i'm not 100
i remember when like i don't know if it
was like palm pilot or something
kind of hit or a cell phone or something
you could do it on and in school because
like we were at the age when like we had
tvs in our school in like senior year
like in high school
so kids could change or like turn it on
and put on like jerry springer
and like the dumb teachers were like
what the hell is wrong with this tv i
will say this i did
we bastard we would during the winter we
would walk around with laser pointers
and uh this was around christmas time
when people had those giant
like snowman floats on their front lawn
and we just aimed the laser pointer at
the snowman floats trying to pop
them and [ __ ] you know would it pop no
no they would never pop
it's a flashlight yeah a couple of a
couple of [ __ ] eggheads over here
let's go down and blow up let's roll up
to santa claus and ruin christmas
quick get the lasers
[Laughter]
johnny's gonna steal his dad's leisure
i thought you were going to say they
used to point them at pilots and try to
hit them in the eyes we would do that
that's like a federal offense cut that
out how strong do you think these lasers
no we're using like we're using like
[ __ ] we're not at the runway yeah
it's illegal hey delta get a load of
this it's illegal it is it's illegal to
point a laser pointer at any kind of
flight yeah but like a real laser
pointer we were using like you know
the one that you could put the top on
and show a naked lady yes yeah yeah yeah
showing they're getting them on the
they're getting them on the boardwalk
wrong they could reach up there no they
can't get the broadway ball is so funny
yeah we're getting like the ball there
were nine bucks you're not taking down
the
jumping ones yeah are you sure
yeah dude but we would we would i mean
if you're hanging out at the airport
yeah don't do it yeah there's like two
different
uh places there's the ones that you get
at the broadway mall or whatever
and then there's the green ones that
were actually they would pop balloons
and you could actually get in trouble
for aiming and we never got those we're
like two hundred
eight two hundred big guys sleeping in
the living room he doesn't have weapons
i'm sleeping in the den
doesn't have a weapons cash
he doesn't have high-end weapons i feel
like if you sleep in the den you
definitely have ninja stars
yeah i agree with toby on that one yeah
but not lasers dude come on i've always
gotten very close to getting weapons
there was a kid in my uh
my when my heel fell through last minute
well i always got scared at the last
minute dude no chocolate milk i just got
here
i would the meetings would go sour
you got the stuff huh you got the bunny
i don't like to smell it
well here in america they didn't know we
had it
who brings gushers to a business meeting
it's
i smell rat yeah yeah you take burger
king gift cards
this guy's wearing a walkman walk you
got the money you got the lasers
there was a kid named like you sure
they'll reach up to a 7 47
yeah they'll reach up to it 7 47 will
they pop a snowman
yeah they'll pop a snowman don't do
anything you want my friend
now that's four packs of dunkaroos let's
go
i'm gonna pee myself
holy [ __ ] that's [ __ ] great yeah
that's so [ __ ] funny man i almost
bought a gun when i was in high school
who'd asked you what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] where did that come from
we were talking about weapons
you jumped to firearms pretty quick yeah
no did you almost buy a gun when i was
in
my junior year of high school there was
this kid in my so illegally
yeah yeah i think so yeah when uh guy
with that jacket doesn't own a legal
firearm yeah yeah
yeah he's not playing about anything
with numbers or have a legal job
no but i i had a i had a class where you
would build uh sets for the
like shows the high school shows so we
would build like sets for them and one
kid was like you want a gun and i was
like yeah
i got really close he was like we got
the gun and i was like i don't want it
anymore
microprocessors frank i'm the guy who
does his job you must be the other guy
we'll probably be at war with valley
high in a few years
selling them guns we're going to need
lasers
listen these are all departed references
everybody's on the same page yeah um
wait was this a kid in school yeah it
was a classmate
wow that's how [ __ ] like you become a
commercial you're blowing your [ __ ]
head off in the den with that thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah do you have the time
he's got the gun
yeah or you know he's playing air guitar
with it yeah yeah
doing drums yeah wait
first or i brought it to school or
something back it up what class
what class did you take where you built
sets for high school it was called
it was called like i forgot what it was
called like stage thingies or something
called sad
yeah yeah yeah were you in the play no i
i auditioned for a lot of plays and i
just never got that's why you bought the
gun
one time i i'll show you i'll show this
artistic director
who can play serpico there's a streetcar
named smith and wesson
wendy
is that a long island trash name no it's
just wendy's
wendy's hey keep up will you bozo jesus
got a usb cord up to this kid's forehead
lee
this guy's this guy's on [ __ ] power
save somebody get me an hour later clear
my head a little bit
you were so innocent what is that long
island trash girl's name i thought you
changed
that's not all you got this is from adam
did you ever insist uh teachers call you
by a name that wasn't your first name
oh yeah like what uncle jesse call me
trail mix
well like you know you know cut on full
house that never really happened but
like you you know sometimes if you were
trying to push a nickname for a while
what was the nickname you pushed
cause last episode we talked about this
you don't give yourself a nickname
you tried to give yourself a nickname i
had a buddy who said yo guys what's up
call me j
hove yeah yeah yeah and he was like 18.
i was like nah dude no no you
never not going for a nickname what was
your nickname brendan i asked people to
call me
pyro cut the tave
we have all we need pyro
the album is called
[Laughter]
no not here not ever
i just took the win now i don't know
why is that because i i wanted to be
like
uh i carried for a long time
oh man go take the safety off you take
the same thing
remember that flames trash they were
like we would have but you didn't
buy the gun well for the longest time
this was also after x-men two came out
um well you're like that kid yeah we got
kids that can't suck you're like a big
iceman fan too
no [ __ ] that no i was always pyro did
and uh i wrote what guys called me
pirates didn't even have a costume
he did a costume in the comics and the
show
all right how old were you 14 maybe
13 14 and uh maybe 15.
and uh yeah i wanted to that was my i
wanted to have that as my personality
the kid who loved fire who was like
so obsessed with fire for a while yeah
it always works out for that kid
[Laughter]
that kid's always welcome at other
people's houses hey
you're talking to a guy who almost
bought a gun is obsessed with fire maybe
be a little bit nicer fidgety what are
you doing to the [ __ ] water sorry
[ __ ] jesus god damn i'm feeling like i'm
on [ __ ] trial here
getting a little hot on these lights
yeah i got a question for you your honor
objection you think pyro could handle
the heat
my dad cheats on his taxes starts giving
everybody
up but make sure they put pyro in the
newspaper okay
pyro rats everybody out
[Laughter]
all right all right let's do one or two
more right now
this has been a fun one thanks for
hanging out my head's spinning
i'm having so much fun uh this is from
comedy artwork shout out to comedy
artwork
uh shout out what is the weirdest thing
you've eaten your car while
actively driving wow the weirdest you
can't do anything with utensils you
gotta go like a
sandwich a soft pretzel a bag of chips
maybe like a diner burger
you've eaten a burger while driving
diner burgers yeah
in the wrapper uh not in the wrapper
there's no rapper with it though there's
no no you like
to take it out of the styrofoam and oh
okay that was a tough one that is a
tough someone's getting the deluxe oh
like a nice
spring for the pickle or like a pickle
like a chipotle burrito or something
like that well the burritos wrapped up
you can do
that's the kind of messy still gets
everything super messy i always do knife
and fork when it comes to burritos
in the car in case anybody's wondering
in the car though
[Laughter]
let's put it in the cup holder yeah
um yeah i don't think i've ever done
anything real crazy
yeah no yeah just like a sammy or maybe
spaghetti
spaghetti yeah if we were like so crazy
like i've done nothing crazy maybe
spaghetti yeah
who's charlie kelly ah probably oh from
always sunny yeah
i like how toby didn't answer me
[Laughter]
just stared at me i don't know no no
i like making any reference past 2003 oh
yeah if it's not caddyshack he doesn't
know what the [ __ ] is going on
back to school maybe ladybugs huh
what the hell is a goonie yeah
um all right one more here yes uh let's
see let's see let's see
uh this is from ian i know you don't
smoke with this um
what cigs but
um actually no let's do this this is for
oh let's do that e and i've i don't want
to [ __ ]
uh have you ever broken his sig and
figured out a way to still smoke it
which is i mean yeah you pinch it
together you pinch either if it's a
whole
you got a pack of bernies would you
steal those out of my pocket oh baby
no you're smoking now i'm smoking
since when no it's okay sometimes i'll
buy a pack if well i'm not drinking so i
need something to [ __ ]
i didn't drink all week and i've been
smoking like a [ __ ] hole yeah but
like i'll finish a pack and then i'm
like
i don't want one for a while and then
two weeks we'll go by and i'll buy
another pack
all right um yeah if you get a hole in
it you gotta
hold but like i've like i've gotten to
the point where like i like
really whittle it down on one end so you
can stick it in and like i kind of make
it together
i've broken one and then taken rolling
papers out of my pocket
and i've used it as a banana as a wrap
yeah yeah that's gross
yeah just throw it out yeah throw it out
throw it well when you're hemmed
i'm not doing it when i got a full pack
of bernie's i'm talking about as i find
one in my car
i would tear the filter off and smoke it
the other way and do it unfiltered
so i wouldn't will you joe camel cool
[Laughter]
copper [ __ ] what's the simpsons
reference the
come on nobody tell them let them burn
habanero
i threw out a gem a couple weeks ago
they left me out to [ __ ] dry that's
why i like utopia it's all movie
references
simpsons and oh he's
his blood sugar gets low he really
starts [ __ ] icing people gang our
friend
brendan
has a brand new album out right now
called not now more than ever
called not now more than ever please go
check it out absolutely fantastic
fantastic episode
thank you everyone for the questions
thank you for signing the patreon thank
you everybody in the facebook group we
love you guys
brandon you got anything else you want
to let people know uh just my socials
uh at brendan sagalow on everything and
uh my podcast garbage days was scott
chaplin
very funny just had him yep uh which by
the way
i think i could whistle better than that
[ __ ] not at all but not at all not
even close but i'll allow it
you know what i do sometimes i'll do
like the french fry just came in
you ever do this you ever eat a bunch of
french fries and bite your finger
uh put all that ketchup on there i have
a podcast with mike feeney and mike
cannon called what's the scenario
at patreon.com scenario pod bleep that
patreon plug
kippy uh
comedy uh on all social media and like i
said please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes keep us in the top 2
hundo we appreciate that
full video available on youtube those
numbers are true to [ __ ] roof thank
you so much and also patreon.com we're
closing in on our next goal
uh guys yeah the the pod's successful
because of you guys i mean you know we
appreciate it
it's all you guys it's we're a [ __ ]
three-man team trying to [ __ ] make
this work i appreciate all the [ __ ]
support from you it's been awesome thank
you so much
we love you guys and we'll see you next
week peace
it's that old pesky uncle hank he's back
he's back he's gonna be talking about
the stereo up again mom
you're goddamn right kids i'm talking
about the stereo app
because we love them all right tonight
january 28th if you're watching this
episode
when it comes out we're going to be
going live on the stereo app
tonight at 9 00 pm it's going to be
uncle hank and kippy
answering your questions we're going to
be talking it's going to be absolutely
fantastic
and i want you to remember something the
stereo app is absolutely amazing
because it's for android and iphone
users okay
and it's not just are you garbage on
there we know that all right
we didn't launch our own app we got
involved with the stereo app
they have a million different things
million different conversations going on
over there
they got pop culture they got lifestyle
they got comedy
anything you could think of any interest
that you have you will find it on the
stereo app it is very neat
and we highly suggest that you guys sign
up and try it out
okay support the businesses that support
the podcast
i'm telling you i was on it last night
it's absolutely fantastic man it's fun
you're be bopping around you're
listening in other conversations
you can get involved you can sit there
and listen whatever you want to do
stereo.com are you garbage sign up
download the app on your phone and sign
up
build yourself an avatar make yourself
look however you want and we will see
you tonight
january 28th 9 p.m january 28th
9 00 p.m that's tonight if you listen to
the episode
the day it came out and i know you are
because you're all
faithful members of the garbagio army
thank you